hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in part three of his on the basis of
morality arthur schopenhauer is going to
unfold for us a ethics of compassion as
being the
real criterion
of moral value or moral worth what it is
that makes things morally good
and he's going to talk about this at
considerable length beginning in chapter
15 and then going on through chapter 60
and then unpacking it in terms of its
two main divisions and actually going on
later on to talk about a metaphysics of
compassion but here we want to get down
how does he derive this
as the the soul criteria and what does
he actually
mean by this so there's a lot to say
because there's a lot going on
here he brings up the criterion of
actions of moral worth actions that can
be said to have moral value an action
here is hanlung so it could be a single
act it could be a course of action
it could be a policy it could be all
sorts of things but something is being
done or
not done and then we're trying to figure
out what makes it good and for
schopenhauer he says that
part of this
is going to be
the lack the absence the not having an
egoistic
motivation so
you know this actually rules out quite a
lot there are a number of actions that
we might view
on the surface as good but they're being
done from an egoistic
motivation
and
he says i'm not going to avail myself of
the clandestine trick of shifting the
matter onto the reader's
conscience you know i'm not going to
play around with that we're going to
actually like strip these things away
there are people of true
integrity and they are not being
motivated in egoistic ways and he says
that we have the exclusion of that class
of motives whereby all human actions are
otherwise prompted namely those are
self-interest in the widest sense of the
term and then he says okay we also have
to make a distinction here so
malice
and you know all the things that fall
under envy cruelty well those are
actually not self-interested
those are aimed at hurting another for
the sake of that hurt not to make
yourself feel good but just to hurt them
you know
it might include elements of joy like
schadenfreude the malicious joy and
others suffering does but um
we need to exclude
those that are that are oriented by
malice and so he says it's obvious that
here such actions cannot be meant
because they're the very opposite of
those we're considering and then he says
i've got some other stuff for you
anybody who insists on the strictness of
the definition may expressively exclude
those actions why because their
essential characteristic is that they
aim at the suffering of others to
produce suffering right moreover actions
of moral worth have a characteristic
that is quite internal
therefore not so evident they leave
behind a certain self-satisfaction
called the approbation of conscious
conscience in the same way the opposite
actions of unjustice and
uncharitableness still more those of
malice and cruelty are affected by an
inner self-censor not everybody
necessarily feels those but then he says
finally there's the secondary and
accidental external characteristic that
acts of the first kind acts that are not
self
self-interested and are not malicious
call forth the approbation and respect
of impartial witnesses
whereas the second produce the opposite
effect so we we've got now you know the
three big motives we're excluding
egoistic motives we're excluding
malicious motives and then he says
hey do you want a proof for this sort of
thing
i'll give you something like that and he
talks about a number of different
hypotheses
axioms that we we can look at
and i'm going to run through these so no
action can take place without a
sufficient motive
axiom number one
an action cannot fail to take place when
there's present a motive that's
sufficient for the character of the doer
unless a stronger counter motive renders
inevitable it's non-performance so we've
got some philosophy of action going on
there
what moves the will what what motivates
is simply wheel and woe in general right
so every motive has a reference to wheel
and whoa
somebody being benefited somebody being
harmed you could say
fourth consequently every action refers
to and has its as its ultimate object a
being
susceptible to wheel and whoa
fifth that being is either the doer
himself or another the other would take
a passive part in the action right
and then sixth every action which has
its ultimate object the wheel and woe of
the doer is egoistic so that's going to
allow us to exclude that
seven all that is said here about
actions applies equally to the
non-performance of such actions for
which motive and counter motive exists
eight as a result of the discussion
given in the previous section egoism and
the moral worth of an action absolutely
exclude each other if an action has as
its motive and egoistic aim it cannot
have moral worth so what we've got here
is a bunch of useful distinctions a
bunch of clarifications
what can we say about this if it is to
have moral worth its motive cannot be an
egoistic aim direct or indirect
near or remote and then finally in
consequence of the elimination in five
of so-called duties to ourselves the
moral significance of an action can lie
only
in its reference to
others
only in respect to these can have moral
worth or worthlessness and accordingly
be an action of justice or philanthropy
as well as the reverse of them and then
he says
from these premises the following is
evident the wheel and woe
which must as its ultimate object
underlie everything done or left undone
are those either of the doer himself
or someone else who plays a passive part
in the action
what does this give us
um
if if you know we're focusing on the
wheel and woe of the other person and
not on ourselves well then we've got
something that is compassion and that is
going to be the only
possible moral incentive
according to schopenhauer it was a very
strong claim
he also
very helpfully
runs through a bunch of clarifications
about what what is egoistic so
you know actions that are done for our
own profit and advantage these are
no-brainers right i mean we might have
some ideologies that that's like you
gotta look out for number one or
everybody has to take care of themselves
or something like that
it's egoistic uh you're not transforming
it into a morally virtuous action by
claiming that greed is good or you know
you should be uh self-motivated
self-centered like everybody else or
anything like that right
now actions aimed at a remote result
you know
what's good for me down the line those
are also egoistic
and so there's no moral worth to them
that doesn't mean that they're bad
right they're not necessarily cruel or
vicious but they're they're not
fundamentally
moral
then we get into some really interesting
ones
what about our good name our reputation
you know the things that are important
for us he says it's no different when we
have in view our honor our reputation in
the eyes of others the esteem of anyone
the sympathy of onlookers and so on
right
so that's kind of interesting um
the esteem
reputation sympathy of others right
it's also no different when we're
obedient to authority which you know
schopenhauer was willing to say a lot of
times we probably should be obedient to
authority
but why what's the motivation
if it's for fear of suffering
consequences fear of suffering woe
then or
wheel being negatively impacted
then that's egoistic
you know we obey the king we obey the
the you know the god that we conceive of
because we're worried about uh secular
or religious sanctions of some sort he
talks about some absolute command that
comes from an admittedly unknown but
obviously superior
authority
what else he talks about our own pride
it is egoism he says that prompts us
when we endeavor to assert by something
done or left undone
on our own high opinion of ourselves and
our own worth and dignity an opinion we
should otherwise have to give up and
therefore see our pride
humbled now that that seems to be a good
thing doesn't it still egoistic
and even he brings up christian wolf who
nobody reads anymore except for a few
specialists but it was you know very
popular uh back then and he talks about
um in accordance with wolff's principles
it's egoism when we try by an action to
work out our own
perfection and by this he means like the
full development of all of our faculties
and capacities our steering ourselves
towards you know goodness in that
respect
still egoistic because focused on the
self
even things that seem to be quite good
are not morally good
from this perspective
so what's compassion like
he tells us
if my action is to be done simply and
solely
for the sake of another
then
his wheel and woe
must be directly my motive just as my
wheel and well were the case in all
other actions and he's and so he says
you know this narrows the expression of
our problem we're going to figure this
out how is it possible for another's
wheel and woe to move my will
directly how is it possible for
another's wheel and woe to become
directly my motive and to such a degree
that i more or less subordinate to them
my own
will and normally the source of my
motives
and then he says there's only one way
the other
person
becoming the ultimate object of my will
in the same way that i myself otherwise
am
through my directly desiring his wheel
and not his woe just as immediately as i
ordinarily do only my own
this is difficult to do this is
difficult to sustain
schopenhauer is not saying that this
happens all that frequently but it does
happen
and what is going on there
we
engage in as he says a kind of
identification
with the
other and now we have to be kind of
careful about this he says
this requires that i am in some way
identified with him in other words that
this entire difference between me
and everyone else which is the very
basis of my egoism is eliminated and
then there's a very important clause
there
to a certain extent at least he's not
saying suddenly you open up to the
universe and you're available to
everybody and you know you're just
compassion all the time no no it's it's
a little bit
getting away from the egoism that
normally
motivates you and he says i don't exist
in the other person's skin
so how can i actually
carry out this identification and he
says
the knowledge that i have of this person
the representation of them in my head
because of this i can identify myself
with them to such an extent that my deed
declares that difference abolish and he
says this is not something that is
imagined
or invented it is perfectly real and
indeed by no means infrequent it is the
everyday phenomenon
of compassion a mid-line
of the immediate participation
independent of all ulterior
considerations primarily in the
suffering of another and thus in the
prevention or elimination of it
for all satisfaction and all well-being
and happiness consist in this
and so this is um
something that schweppenhauer thinks
that at least most of us we all have the
potential for this some of us experience
this from time to time in our own
actions you know you see the
drowning
kitten and you go over and pluck it out
of the river and comforted or something
like that were you trying to were you
doing that because you were like well i
need a kitten for a stage prop oh
there's a kitten right there that would
be egoistic
just the direct
i reach out i do something is
compassion
and this identification like you said
happens through representation
foreshadowing right
a little bit later he's going to say
something very important he's trying to
avoid an error
and he talks about this casino
and his analytic essay on compassion
his view is that compassion arises from
an instantaneous deception of the
imagination we put ourselves in the
position of the sufferer and have the
idea we are suffering his pains in our
person schopenhauer says
that's not what identification is
we're not i'm not feeling that other
person's pain in me
i am bothered by the fact that they are
pain he says
we remain clearly conscious that he is
the sufferer not we
it's precisely in his person not in ours
that we feel the suffering to our grief
and sorrow
we suffer with him and hence
in him we feel his pain as
his we do not imagine it is ours
if you're imagining that it's yours he
doesn't go ahead and say this but if
you're just imagining that it's yours
that's still egoistic right because you
only care about the other person because
you've got this weird emotional
contagion going on
real compassion
lowers a kind of boundary but also
recognizes that there is a
differentiation there is a boundary
between
ourselves and those the other people
he also tells us something very
important that compassion is less
focused and less directly focused on the
well-being of the other and in promoting
that well-being and more in alleviating
their suffering so it's it is about the
you know uh
the wheel and the woe of the other but
you could say that it's more about the
woe
and how we
help them
out of that um
he says that the reason for this is that
pain suffering that includes all want
privation need in fact every wish and
desire is that which is positive and
directly felt and experienced on the
other hand the nature of satisfaction
enjoyment and happiness consists solely
in the removal of a privation the style
the stilling of the pain and so these
have a
negative effect so we're going to be
more oriented by
making other people
less unhappy than we are going to be by
making them more
happy
the last thing that he says which leads
us into the next sections
is that
what this is going to take the form of
are two very
broad overarching we can call them
virtues toughened in
german
and these are
justice or you know literally
rightness doing right by other people
and then loving-kindness which we could
also translate as benevolence or as
philanthropy
and these two are going to be as he says
uh tied in with these two important
clauses injure no one on the contrary
help everyone as much as you can and
these are going to be at least in some
respects motivated
by
something of genuine moral worth namely
compassion
you